and by the time the Soviet revolution
came around which would be at the latter
part of the 1910s after the First World
War the peasant class had actually
established farms of course varying
productivity some of the peasant farmers
were very very good at being farmers and
produced a huge proportion of Russia's
and Ukraine's food because one of the
things we'll talk about this later as
the class progress is one of the things
that you'll find is that if you look at
creative production in any domain it
doesn't matter
artistic domain food production novels
written novels souls money generated
number of companies generated number of
goals scored in hockey etc any or not
number of paintings painted number of
compositions written anything like that
where where the fundamental underlying
measure is human productivity what you
find is that a very tiny percentage of
people produce almost all the output
it's called a Pareto distribution var
eto and it was studied in detail in
scientific productivity by someone named
de Sola price it's a square root law so
here's the law fundamentally if you look
at the number of people who are doing
who are who are in a given domain who
are producing in a given domain the
square root of the people produce half
the product so that means if you have
ten employees three of them do have to
work but if you have ten thousand
employees a hundred of them do have to
work right it's a very very vicious
statistic and you won't learn about that
in psychology for reasons I have no idea
about because you learn about the normal
distribution and not the Pareto
distribution but Pareto distributions
govern for example the distribution of
money which is why one percent of the
people in the general population have
the overwhelming amount of money and one
tenth of that one percent has almost all
of that right so I think it's like the
richest hundred people in the world have
as much money as the bottom two and a
half billion and you think well that's a
terrible thing and perhaps it is but
what you have to understand is that that
law governs the distribution of creative
production across all creative domains
right it's something like a natural law
and we can we'll talk about that more
but imagine what happened
when you play Monopoly you've all played
Monopoly what happens when you play
Monopoly one person ends up with all the
money all right then you play another
game of Monopoly what happens one person
ends up with all the money it's actually
the inevitable consequence of multiple
trades that are conducted randomly so if
you take a thousand people and you get
them to play a trading game you get two
each give them a hundred dollars say or
ten dollars and they have to trade with
another person by flipping a coin I win
the coin toss you give me a dollar you
win I give you a dollar if we all play
that long enough one person will end up
with all the money and everyone else
will end up with zero so it's a deeply
built feature of systems of creative
production and no one really knows what
to do about it because of course the
danger is is that all the resources get
funneled to a tiny minority of people at
the top and a huge section of the
population stacks up at zero but to
blame that on the oppressive nature of a
given system is to radically
underestimate the complexity of the
problem no one actually knows how to
effectively shovel resources from the
minority that that controls almost
everything to the majority that has
almost nothing in any consistent way
because as you shovel money down it
tends to move right back up and it's a
big problem anyways the reason I'm
telling you about that is because after
the peasants were were granted their
land and started to become farmers a
tiny minority of them became extremely
successful and those people produced
almost all of the food for Russia and
Ukraine so what happened in the 1920s
when bloody Lenin came along and
collectivized the farms with that they
defined the kulaks who were these tiny
minority of successful farmers who maybe
had a brick house and were able to hire
a couple of people and had some land and
some livestock and we're very productive
people they define them as socially
unfriendly elements and they sense
groups of intellectuals out in fitted
towns to collectivize the farms and so
the idea was that while you would pool
your land and and everyone would farm it
collectively and the land was taken away
of course from the tiny minority of
people who are actually productive and
had actually managed to own much of the
land so you have to imagine how that
would occur okay so it's in the nineteen
20s it's after the world after world war
1 Russia's in pretty bad shape the
villages are full of brutalized men who
have post-traumatic stress disorder and
lots of people who are not doing well at
all and the bloody intellectuals come
into the town and they say you know
those successful farmers up the street
that you've always been pretty jealous
about in your useless manner well there
are actually pigs and demons who are
stealing from you so why don't you come
out we'll form a nice little mob and
we'll take everything they've got and
that's exactly what happened and all
those people were killed or raped or set
off to Siberia in the middle of the
bloody winter where there wasn't even
anything for them to - anywhere for them
to live or anything for them to eat so
they all died and then the consequence
of that was a few years later 6 million
people starved to death in the Ukraine